he was maybe in that moment she was
trying to kill somebody but the point
that we should be focused on is that
micaiah bryant
like to promote peace in her spare time
right i mean this is like
i feel like we have now tapped in to
fiction like now we have to just accept
fiction it doesn't matter because makaya
bryant was black and she at the hands of
police officer and that's all that
matters now people want to come out and
they want to support micaiah bryant
maybe she too like george floyd will be
buried into a gold casket maybe
eventually one day nancy pelosi will say
that mikaya bryant's name will be
synonymous synonymous with justice
let me tell you what is actually
happening in america at this time if
you're a black american you better pay
attention
right now in america the goal is to make
sure that black people
love and support criminality
that is the goal the express goal now is
to make black people believe that we
should be in the streets rioting and
looting and demanding justice for
criminals right because that is what
these people are they're criminals
george floyd was in the process of
committing a crime i'm not saying he
deserved to die i don't think anybody
deserves to die i think he deserved to
be arrested
they attempted to arrest him did you
forget that part have you seen the full
video of his arrest the media refuses to
show the full video that shows the
police tried to put him into the vehicle
multiple times and he resisted arrest by
saying i'm claustrophobic i'm
claustrophobic because he had just
ingested fentanyl fentanyl that thing
that's a hundred times more potent than
morphine but then you come to a point of
duty of care is that the guy was high on
drugs wherever he's made that mistake
but to equate that that it's almost
she's putting on it's his fault that he
died is he's
i don't think she's fair to say that
that's
that's neither that's not a hero there's
like any other crime if if someone was
graped you'd never say to them ah but
they were right walking out late at
night or they're wearing that type of
clothing so for this kind of crime
why is that used
as a supplement to me our kids
some
unlawful word lost their life i would
well for grape
yeah i mean i think there's situations
you shouldn't put yourself in as a woman
and it's not something
i hate it just like i don't think it's
smart to resist arrest yeah i don't
think it's my eye but what i'm saying is
she's almost trying to use that as an
argument and when if you had to switch
it to great i guarantee most of society
wouldn't allow that as an argument if
most of but we're in the free thinking
space here
and i i would never blame someone but i
would say hey
you can look at that situation yeah and
think maybe don't put yourself in that
situation right here like everyone knows
that you know that where's that goes out
and has no way she's getting home like
she doesn't know how she's getting yeah
and it's like if you go out at night
wearing nothing that's like
i'm not i'm not saying like what do you
think is gonna happen but like honestly
if you're by yourself you don't have a
guy to protect you like what but can you
see my argument because even though we
are in the free thinking space can you
see how people are allowed this is an
argument but if you change it to grape
people would be like oh my god how could
she ever make this argument
i could see what you're saying i just
don't think like
it's right
because i just i think like you
shouldn't resist arrest from an officer
yeah and it puts both of you at risk
because now the officer like you you see
in so many of these cases people
resisting arrest yeah i wouldn't do that
yeah it's just not smart
so
like i had a cousin that was addicted to
drugs and he had some bad interactions
with the police but i was like you know
what he's also a crackhead
like
like a lot of the [ __ ] that like people
complain about he would complain about
but i'm like well
he's a crackhead like he would say
police robbed him
they might have i don't know but
at the end of the day my cousin was a
crackhead so like
what what value does a crackhead have in
terms of robbery like what are you gonna
do yeah he said if he ever had cash on
it and he would get arrested like they
would always take it it's probably for
his better so he doesn't speak drugstore
well i know that's still illegal
but probably done in favors
look at i don't know
well actually funny thing is he actually
got
real like there was one time the police
did mistreat him and he proved it and he
got let off for the crime that he
committed that's sick yeah because they
um illegally searched him like they
didn't have a reason to search him
that's like our one of our friends we
had in the podcast
he went to prison
then it got overturned
um but they didn't want to pay him
compensation so they said they gave him
like jail time on credit so if it goes
joe again
he gets
automatically served
wow
that's the bridge how long was he in
jail uh he's done like three years but
he did an extra
like four months then he should have
said like yeah if you ever come back you
get four months off
that is so [ __ ] up i was [ __ ] up in
it because we even banned it we're like
ah so what did you get in credit is that
yeah i did
sorry i should have been laughing that's
a horrible yeah it's mad you see the tik
tok clip people were laughing
but um no with my cousin though like
honestly like
i don't know i just always be like i
need to crack it
like i'm sure some of the shitty comp
was complaining about was true but at
the end of the day i'm like why are you
cracking i do get it though like people
forget they're human because i used to
work in security here so like
like we call them bouncers but over
there you call them i don't know like
doormen and nightclubs and they don't
realize like at some point
people take the piss so much you're just
gonna end up beating someone up because
you asked them a million times you've
tried to remove them nicely
i'm just gonna choke you and remove you
because you're pissing me off now yeah
yeah so i hear it he had just ingested
it because he didn't want to again get
caught with a controlled substance as he
had done repeatedly throughout his life
let's ignore testimony from his
girlfriend who said that they were both
addicted which by the way that is sad
drug addiction is sad we can be talking
about drug addiction we should be
talking about drug addiction that would
be a meaningful discussion but instead
let's ignore all of these things that
would help us fix black america let's
let's not talk about drug abuse let's
not talk about drug dealers let's not
talk about criminality let's not talk
about why micaiah bryant had a knife and
was trying to stab a woman to death
let's just talk about black victimhood
because the discussion about black
victimhood almost guarantees us that in
the future black neighborhoods are only
going to get worse
when you start celebrating criminals
that is of course what is going to be
the end result we're going to have more
black death we're going to produce more
black failures because we're not allowed
to talk about the truth anymore and
republican democrats are even saying
that this is good right so let's not
talk about it it's just been agreed the
lie has been agreed upon don't say
anything if you tell the truth canis
you're a bad person
i don't care what i am called just
because right now in this country we are
facing a pandemic of cowardice because
people are too scared once the mob says
that this is what must be said and these
are the only things that can be said
because the media has now created a
system a successful
system of propaganda where people don't
even know what the truth is because the
lie has been said over and over and over
again that does not mean that i'm going
to back down to the truth in fact i
think more than ever now we need to have
people that are willing to stand up and
to say that what is happening in this
country is wrong what is happening in
this country is backwards
none of these people that i mentioned
are heroes
thanks for joining me on this segment of
candace if you like this video subscribe
to this youtube channel and ring the
bell to get notifications on new videos
okay would you
so watching it back do you feel the same
way about her um i think when i first
watched candy's owens as we know the
institutions are very leftist i think i
was very deep
in my leftist side of thinking so
it doesn't bother me as it did as much
in the time i see where she's coming
from i think and one of the reasons i
watched but obviously we'll just talk
about this one is
i feel like in many causes
that happen that are positive